my passion is a direct result of all of
the pain and all of the struggle and all
of the failures
I wouldn't change a thing growing up in
a pretty high achieving family one of
the things that was always emphasized
was to not spend more than you make and
that you're completely in control of
your circumstances I was the heavy kid
in a pretty fit active family and my mom
wasn't really okay with that and now she
admits that she felt like my weight
problem was a reflection on her as a
parent so there was a lot of talk about
you know so many talents and gifts
imagine what you could do if you just
lost that weight I wanted to be a high
achiever in every regard not just
financially but with my health in fact
so much so that I walked away from a
full scholarship in Latin and Greek to
study nutrition as an obese teenager
because I wanted more than anything to
tackle it and I was over 300 pounds I
wasn't thinking about what it would look
like when it came time to repay that
debt and so when I got married and I
realized between my husband's flight
school and my student loans we have one
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
debt and we didn't get to do with our
money what we wanted to we had to pay
that student loan debt and I just
decided I want more freedom than that I
am a big reader I'm always taking on new
books and when I picked up financial
piece it really taught me how to stay in
the moment all I had to worry about was
today we had paid off all of our debt
that was great we owned a home that was
great I had a job that I was really good
at but why is it then I can achieve all
these other things and I can have total
tunnel vision and commitment to a goal
but not be able to achieve the weight
loss that I wanted and I decided it was
time to unlearn everything I learned in
school and transform this because I have
what it takes and now's the time to do
it
for me taking control of my finances was
really a turning point to allow me to
take control of everything in my world I
really wanted to take a common-sense
approach to these changes this time
around what I came to learn and
understand cuz I'm a big reader and
researcher is that the idea that all we
need to do is eat less and move more is
totally flawed all of a sudden when I
started taking kind of a common-sense
approach to what my body needed and
wanted it was so much easier than it had
ever been after I had lost about 130
pounds so many people were saying what
did you do how did you do this what was
the lightbulb moment how do you stay
motivated and I was like you know what
this is so pervasive and it's not just a
health issue it's a quality of life
issue and so I decided to launch final
potential and use my story to help other
people create for themselves the really
common sense approach to natural fat
loss hey everybody welcome back to the
primal potential podcast
I'm your host Elizabeth bendin and I'm
so glad that you've taken time out of
your day to hang out with me and talk
about what is holding you back and I
know for so many of my clients when they
start to control their mindset they're
better able to make great food choices I
have to remind myself all the time to
not get out in front not worry about
what I'm gonna do tonight or what I'm
gonna do next week and so this is a
constant reminder for me what is my best
in this moment motivation isn't
something that just strikes you it's
actually something you choose to create
every day I have to consciously choose
my focus throughout the day all day
every day
I've graffiti'd my treadmill desk with
some of those phrases that motivate me I
have them on the wall to be relentlessly
positive when I look at it now I am
happy to know that my passion comes from
my pain
I see it as the raw material there like
the bricks to my building but I am
defined by what I do and that is a gift